do you have a PhD
no I just graduate from college
to have five years
in characterizing
including syngenic tumors and
genetically engineered house models
you know the job description says no
experience was necessary
how about 10 years experience in swallow
through Target identification engagement
and Foundation
no one last question have you spent
around 25 years on researching and
developing the cure to cancer by any
chance
it's ready to
oh
okay well thank you for your time it was
great getting to know and talk with you
we will send a follow-up email within a
week or so and you can always just ask
us questions if you have any questions
well have a nice day